Taylor Swift and boyfriend Joe Alwyn  hold hands in NYC  the 27 year old singer and the 26 year  old actor were spotted after Taylor's  performance at Madison Square Garden on  Friday night the low-key couple looked  happy showing PDA while walking hand in  hand Taylor looked edgy in a colorful  coat that showed off her long legs she  paired the ensemble with black studded  combat boots and festive green and red  nail polish  while her beau who she reportedly wrote  her song gorgeous about or a dark jacket  jeans and dress shoes for the outing the  couples seemed to be making their  relationship more public little by  little and have been together for some  time now Alwyn and Swift were first  pictured together back in June while in  her adopted hometown of Nashville  Tennessee  [Music]  you